it's absolutely great I think for both
of us to be here and we're we're going
to do this as a bit of a a a real
conversation but um with some unreal
bits I
think and I wanted to
start simply by asking Rory about what
we're talking about when we talk about
power you know I'm tempted to say look
you've got you know one of the country's
most successful podcasts you've got a
book which is you know week after week
in the best seller list you've got uh
you're involved in a charity that has
got enormous
impact does that feel like power or I
think I would put it better to say what
does it feel like to feel you have power
and how far a kind of traditional
politics always Senter stage in
that right well thank you I mean I I
find that um one of the secrets of
modern British life is the sense that it
often feels as though there isn't any
power
anywhere and so politicians spend a lot
of time I don't know thinking that
journalists have power and the
journalists maybe think the business
people have power and the business
people maybe think the politicians have
power and so on and so
forth the reality of being a minister is
very very odd so when I was um Secretary
State for International Development I
was in charge of a budget of 20 billion
US a year so
13,000 million pound a year with almost
no constraint it was legally protected
by an act of parliament there was no
interference from the treasury there was
no interference from the Prime
Minister and yet oddly it didn't feel
like the kind of power that I had when I
was running a small charity on the
ground in
Afghanistan so when I was on the ground
in Afghanistan I was under buildings we
had a couple hundred staff I could see
water supply going in I could see
clinics being built I could get involved
in the design of a balcony or worry
about where the electricity system was
coming in as a sex State you sit in an
enormous office and you sign Bits of
Paper that's like being a Roman Emperor
you know we come back I this is so I I
want to I'm going to throw that back at
you um it it is something that interests
me I mean you have the idea that
somebody like the emperor hadrien has a
lot of
power but of course he can only be in
one place at one time now he travels
around a great deal but wherever he is
he's just here and what he's doing at
the other end of the Empire is
presumably a takes a certain amount of
time for the message to get through but
B is dependent on person after person
after person he can't actually I don't
know if he's standing in Britain worry
too much about exactly what's happening
in the design of a forum in Spain no
that's true and in in the Roman
Empire you can explain if you want to I
don't think it's the complete
explanation but you can explain the
powerlessness of the person apparently
in power on practical infrastructural
grounds know that know you've got your
governor in beinia and he's asked you a
question but the Letter's taken three
months to get to you and it's going to
take three months for you to send the
reply by which time he's going to have
to have made his own mind up you know
you cannot control that and I think
ancient historians and I'm you know I'm
guilty here we we blame that you know on
the practicalities of it but of course
when talking to someone like
you and saying well how does it feel
like to be a
minister as a minister you can
communicate instantly but you still have
that sense that things are going on
around you and you're not controlling
them and in a sense there is a you know
where we think power is there's often a
kind of black hole where the person
apparently wielding it and I think
that's an interesting word um is you
know is is it in the wondering what the
hell to do aren't they yeah I mean it's
this is partly I mean something I think
be definitely worth uh talking to Mary
much more about which is the bureaucracy
because of course the reality is that
and and Mary's wonderful book which if
any of you haven't bought you must read
um is very very good on the fact that on
the surface there are very very few
civil servants working in the r system a
lot of soldiers an enormous number of
soldiers compared to the population but
surprisingly few people that we would
describe as civil servants running this
whole setup but my experience as a
minister is that the relationship and I
don't know whether this would be true of
an emperor with uh an Emperor's civil
servants but certainly I changed in my
life from being a civil servant I was
briefly a British soldier I was then a
diplomat in the foreign office and I
thought when I became a minister I was
just like a senior civil servant so I
could sit around a table and I could
have a sort of debate like a seminar
about what to do or what not to do and
we'd come to a conclusion I'd make a
decision it would happen nothing of the
sort it's completely impossible to do
things like that I realized very very
slowly that to get anything done I had
to actually do what I hated doing which
is create the three-word slogan reach
over the head to the public so in
prisons for example I spent um nearly
six months having a discussion on what
we could do about violence and prisons I
was getting absolutely nowhere was only
when I said to the BBC I will resign in
12 months unless violence comes down in
prisons that I then got some power then
suddenly I could set up an operations
room I could focus on 10 prisons some
money came my way the Civil Service sort
of woke up they had a Target to aim for
and everybody got behind the idea um and
I I'm I wonder whether there's
a anything that we can see of that
whether maybe and I I was thinking we
were talking about this in the Green
Room whether Emperors can't change small
things but they can occasionally pull
huge leevers so they can for example we
were talking about I can't remember who
is is it sep seus who suddenly makes
everybody citizen car okay so so how
does that work you wake up one day and
you suddenly think you're going to make
everybody a Roman
citizen those big changes are of course
the changes that none of us can actually
explain I mean you can see that the
Roman Empire quite
resiliently carries on probably a bit by
luck um as much as anything else you
know don't get found out they don't ask
too much um the idea of Roman control is
a very limited uh bit of
control what you have in the
middle is a guy who if he's
successful has learned to act the part
of the emperor it's its performance
politics I suspect is not unlike our own
um and then very occasionally in the
history of what 300 years of the the
Roman Empire you find someone like caraa
who's a frightful Bruiser by all
accounts in an absolute hard-headed
shitfaced guy right suddenly he
says every free person in the Roman
Empire will be a citizen it's the
biggest Grant of citizenship to ever
made anywhere ever can I can I interrupt
a second so this is a guy who's he's a
professional military man he's quite
sort of tough he's quite ruthless and
then suddenly he manages to do this
quite extraordinary political thing I'm
not sure I mean he does have a good
reputation with the soldiers and he kind
of dresses up quite convincingly part of
the ACT you know little military skirts
um um and you know he's he's a guy who's
gone down in history as as in a kind of
nasty I mean his nastiest moment was um
having his his brother who was partly a
co-ruler with him his brother Gator
murdered in the palace um put to death
on his mother's lap well Gator Cried Out
apparently and this is either a
hopelessly pathetic moment in Roman
history or terribly poignant he said um
Mommy Mommy I'm being
killed and that carala is The Mastermind
here um he's eventually assassinated by
uh soldiers in the middle of a pee
actually he's having a pee while on
campaign and they choose that the moment
to do him in but his his major claim to
fame is this massive extension of
citizenship and we cannot understand why
he did it but but it's possible it's an
incredibly imaginative bold liberal
political step which transforms the way
the Empire works that is how we would
like to to see it and that appeals to us
um the only ancient explanation of it
the and we don't have to believe this is
that actually he was short of cash and
he thought if he gave everybody
citizenship they'd all become liable to
inheritance tax now seems to me that's a
sledgehammer to crack in arch really you
know but but it's you know it's the the
madness the craz
or at least the inexplicability of why
people in government in power do what
they do so I guess the the reason I'm
interested in in the emperor what he's
up to um is that one one of the odd
things certainly when you look at
European politics over the last few
hundred years is that frequently these
rather brutal nasty people can
occasionally do something which is
really transforming and peculiar I mean
they take power in a very very Sinister
way and then they managed to uh achieve
things I mean the classic example of
this in in the US is is Lyndon Johnson
if you haven't read Robert Caro's
extraordinary four volume biography of
of of Lyndon Johnson do so Johnson is
corrupt violent we talk about peeing um
uh in his case he was perpetually taking
out his penis in front of other senators
in order to impress them in the
washrooms and he assisted in essentially
humiliating people with his enormous
height he was corrupt he almost
certainly had people killed and yet he
was the man who introduced the first
civil rights legislation in the United
States he was the man who transform
civil rights in the United States and so
I I it's
possible that kakal is simply uh after
the money it's possible and or we can
look at um look at nor iseland uh Ian
pesy Jr for some reason that is still
very difficult to understand when all
his political interests were lined up
with continuing to reject the peace
process having rejected the peace
process since the early 1970s towards
the end of his life flips and uses his
political Capital to do something very
dangerous Lyndon Johnson wiped out the
Democratic Party in the South and I
think that decision is interesting
because there must have been quite a lot
of Romans who were very proud to be
citizens who were deeply deeply
affronted that something that they saw
as very special had suddenly been given
to every Tom Dick and Harry yeah um and
it's it causes all kinds of confusion um
one one bit of confusion is that almost
everybody in the Roman empire ever after
is called aurelus because you take the
name you take your Roman citizen name
from the person who gave you the surname
of the person who gave you citizenship
so everybody suddenly is called the same
him is called off to him um but it's it
is one of those things which is um and I
think there isn't really another example
of that quite in Roman history where
this transformative
moment comes out of the blue from
someone who you would never remotely
expect and you know and I still find it
hard to think of
as a as a sweet liberal guy who really
wanted to extend the Privileges of Roman
power you know doesn't seem very likely
to me but that was the effect of what he
did but I guess my point is Linda
Johnson was definitely not a sweet
liberal cuddly guy exact I I I wanted
also very interested in the book about
thinking about the size of Rome and its
budget so we we often talk about Rome
and the Empire as being enormous but in
your book book I think you say the
population is about 50 million people
which is smaller than the United Kingdom
today yes so in a sense when this
horrible man Boris Johnson who's Ascent
to power you facilitate it by putting
him on a stage um uh Fair all your all
your fault all your fault um becomes
prime minister he is actually governing
more people uh than a Roman Emperor and
he's also involved in much more
dimensions of people's lives a Roman
Emperor I mean a Roman Emperor you point
out is spending about 50% of the budget
on the military yeah they're not running
a National Health Service they're not
running a full education system they're
not and any of the sort of thing they're
not running a welfare state they're not
running pensions so the a modern British
government to some extent has more power
than any Roman Emperor could could dream
of over a smaller territory I mean I
think Rome is this extra
ordinary um pretense of power when
actually the guy in the middle closer
you get you see that he there's very
very little that he can do and that
leaves you the question and it leaves us
the question I think too is if the guy
the figurehead is not doing this who the
hell is and I in in Rome I that is
almost impossible I think to pin down
I mean what we see is we see um two
things simultaneously we see the Roman
Emperor if they're good at it performing
the rituals of
power and we see people on the
outside the critics at least worried
actually that all that the Roman Emperor
is is an actor and I that doesn't seem
to me to be too far from some of our
anxieties I mean I'm not a you know I I
I'm not wanting to attack rishy sunak
here but um I think one place where we
saw that was when he went out just to
demonstrate the British populace that we
were all in it together with fuel prices
you know and he was filling up a smaller
car than he had ever owned using a
petrol pump that he was clearly very
inexperienced at and not quite knowing
how to pay now at that point we
say is that guy is he is he just a bad
actor you know and where do we put the
boundary between you know the authentic
leader and the guy who's playing at it
and and it's it's it's fascinating
actually if you look at a lot of what's
Happening uh on Twitter x a lot of
what's happening with AI and um deep
fakes a lot of it is about exposing
apparent disconnects between who they
seem to be in the public and who they
really are and it's it's one of the real
tricks of the deep fakes so there was
one actually about Rishi sunak where um
you see him failing to pull a pint and a
woman standing behind him looking in
horror turns out this is untrue turns
out this is a faked up photo but it's
very very successful because it hits an
instinct we have that of course he
wouldn't be able to pull a p and of
course the bar bar the lady behind the
bar would not prove it it's the same
with um a deep fake they just did on K
where they have a sort of apparent sort
of very crackly recording of him
shouting at an aid for dropping his iPad
notice these deep fakes are not really
Grand things they're not making Kama
give a speech he didn't give it's tiny
accidental Court moments and again a lot
of Mary's book is is about people trying
to discredit Emperors with glimpses of
how they behave at the dinner table or
what kind of food they serve or this
sort of thing yeah or I mean I think in
the case of Nero um you know a lot of
these lurd anecdotes have actually got
much more bottom in them about about an
analysis of Empire
than most people ever realized I mean we
love the stories or classical historians
love the stories about you know Nero
going to the theater and of course he's
desperate to be an actor and he demeans
himself because he performs on stage and
oh he's he's so vain that he has the
theater doors locked so that no one can
leave the performance um until he's
finished you know and there're wonderful
stories about women giving you've
actually done that tonight that is oh
that's true don't try to leave guys
don't try um you know women give birth
so I hope there's no hope that's not
going to happen women give birth and and
uh others pretend to drop down dead so
they can be carried out
and and the these are great you're
laughing and I laugh and I think they're
wonderful anecdotes uh and but they're
more than that because actually what
they're saying is not just Nero was
crazy you know and look how vain he was
they're saying here is the
Emperor being an actor for real and what
does that tell us about how he normally
is is he ever not an actor I I also
think some of the characters in your
book I mean Mary opens with this
description of this extraordinary young
teenager who comes over from HPS in
Syria and becomes the Roman emperor in
his in his early teens
and I wonder with a lot of these people
the things for which they're criticized
n is criticized for being an actor
alabas is criticized for apparently
trying to change his
gender uh Commodus gets it in the neck
because he appears in gladiatorial
fights but to some extent one wonders
whether one doesn't sympathize with
these young men being trapped in a role
and that maybe you know maybe goodness
near probably does think when he talks
whatever his Roman equivalent of
therapist is I've always wanted to be an
actor
act you know and he says you know what
an artist dies with me when you know his
famous last words um because they they
really have that option right you you're
made an emperor and you're supposed to
be a pretty kind of yeah but you're
supposed to you know grow a big beard
like hadrien and all well only look let
me give you a tip you only grow a big
beard if you're a second century Emperor
so I'll tell you if you ever wonder how
to tell Emperors apart a good tip it's
if they've got a beard their second
century and you don't think that's
hedrin also trying to show he's one of
the men Macho Soldier kind of or he's
trying to show that he's a Greek
philosopher you know I mean how do you
know
but I I think that I suppose when I was
writing the book and I want to turn this
on to you in a way cuz I want to know
how sorry I should feel for you um very
very sorry sorry very very sorry you
know I thought in the end look I you
know I hate autocracy I've been brought
up to think that it's vile and awful and
I still kind of think that I still do
think that but you know I looked at
these Ordinary People you know with all
their frailties having to pretend that
they were the rulers of the Known World
in an
impossible um administrative structure
not knowing what was going on and in
particular I've I think knowing at some
level if they thought about it that no
one would ever tell them the truth
anyway I thought this was you know this
was a job from
hell then I thought well how does how
does that equate with both ministerial
or prime ministerial power in this
country I mean do do I imagine when
you're a secretary of state or when
you're prime
minister who tells you the
truth
um well it's it's I mean I think this is
probably the experience maybe of of of
Roman Empress 2 um some people really
take pride in telling you the truth in
an extremely cudly non-constructive
fashion I mean there are many people who
really like the idea that I'm speaking
truth to power in fact it's one of the
most tedious things in the world right
rather than actually having a sensible
conversation somebody really wants to
put themselves on their pedestal I'm
telling you how it really is um I think
what um I feel when I think about being
a Roman Emperor um is that they will
have
experienced um a very very strong sense
of public distrust and Loathing I mean
one of the odd things is that the Roman
Empire continues for a very long time
but basically they are portrayed as
greses and a lot of the Romans writing
about them seem to basically think their
entire political system is
noxious and that seems a bit familiar I
mean I think you know 70% of British
people in a recent poll basically feel
powerless feel the political system is
broken feel our democracy as a sham feel
our politicians are incompetent corrupt
useless
people and at the same time of course
when I am a politician
performing I can never ever be good
enough and this will be true I think if
you're a rem Emperor it doesn't matter
how fluent I am it doesn't matter how
funny I am it doesn't matter how clever
I am I will never ever be able to know
enough everybody in this room will be
able to catch me out on something
everybody in this room will have One
Moment One anecdote oh well we can't
trust this person because we know he did
XY Z in other words you are set up day
in day out whether on social media or on
the media for for humiliation and
failure and and and the stakes are
aranged so that you can never live up to
actually in some ways the rather foolish
standards that you're being asked to
live up to I mean I I think o often uh I
you know I think about Roman emperor
when I read an article in the newspaper
and it's signed by the Prime
Minister and I think partly I think oh
so the Prime Minister wrote that and
then I think no he didn't um you know
some you know he put his name to it he
probably read it um but um it it isn't
do I think it's his word when when
someone gives a speech you know I know
the great you know the great I'm putting
this in commas the great lines of
Margaret Thatcher were not written by
Margaret Thatcher you know sometimes she
it's clear she didn't even understand
what the speech writers had written you
know when she says the lady is not for
turning she doesn't seem to get that
it's a a parody of the lady is not for
burning um and and yet still right down
there I'm still saying well I don't like
this because it's not he's not real well
in a way no politician can be real just
like no Emperor could be real and
they're caught on the same um helpless
hopelessly idealistic standard when Nero
gives the speech uh at his uh adopted
father claudius's funeral gives the
eulogy um tacitus writes with barbed
words that uh Nero he said didn't write
the speech
it was his tutor senica who wrote the
speech Nero was the first Roman Emperor
to use borrowed
words our politicians use borrowed words
all the time except I don't every speech
this authenticity embodied
authenticity this is important because I
think one of the problems with
historians is that you can be overly
cynical overly cynical right you you
actually are worse sometimes than
journalists you assume the whole thing
the whole thing is a sh whole thing is a
sh no no but this is important because I
believe tacitus when he says that and I
can tell the difference between
colleagues of mine for whom speeches
were written yeah and people like me who
never ever delivered a speech that was
written by someone else but you don't
believe it you assume every time you
hear me speak every article you read
somebody else that I haven't done it
someone else wrong and you may be wrong
about Nero's
predecessors
okay at that point I'm just going to say
because we're about halfway through our
conversation here that um in another 25
minutes or so we'll be opening up to uh
questions both people who are listening
online um there'll be roving mics uh in
the body of the hall and there's two
fixed mics um on the gallery so so
that's what we're going to move to at
about uh 85 wonderful so I'm going to
I'm going to follow up because you
raised
tacitus um so um testas for those of you
who haven't read testas definitely worth
reading testas I I think the probably
the best histo I mean the the historian
most worth reading which is different
from best most worth reading who has
ever lived right um I mean so put that
on the back cover so I mean so so
mesmerizing and very unluckily we don't
have all of tacitus the stuff that he
wrote closer to his own life he became a
a working serving politician uh has
vanished we have his earlier stuff and
some of the earli stuff I think was only
turned up in some Monastery in Germany
or the Netherlands pretty belated agria
did yes relatively so it's anyway what
we have is somebody who
is very very very angry he's both a
somebody who works within the system has
got promoted has done reasonably
well has got these sort of commands out
of Emperor but is also just disgusted
with his fellow politicians disgusted
with his fellow senators and again and
again he's describing the ways in which
they're being cowardly greedy dishonest
failing to live up to his vision of what
prop political conduct should be that
that's true I mean as I say I'm I'm
tas's number one fan he's my desert
island Burke I think
um he is extraordinarily
Twisted um and he is looking at the
culture under the first Empress um up to
basically the first century
CE uh and wondering how to be able to
express his disgust there is you know
there is no almost no good person in
tests the the opposition to Roman
emperors uh are a load of complete
walles who can never get it right and
just have you know have no forward plan
they just kind of moan the sort of their
vocal dissident but nothing else the
Emperors themselves are utterly corrup
and he he's trying to
express what it is to live in a world
where political power um is poisoned
basically and one of the reasons that
tacitus is very difficult to read I mean
he's kind of really the the Roman
literature's equivalent of finegan wake
in part of what he does is he's trying
also to say you know you can't even
write about the corruption of this power
without corrupting the very language in
which you write about it so it's an
extraordinary um brilliant attempt to
nail corruption wherever you see
it and it's you know absolutely
Unforgettable I mean the favorite um
quip for me is his description in a his
work agrica the biography of his
father-in-law who was governor of Roman
Britain um the the horrible bomo about
what the effect of Roman imperialism is
um when he says they make a desert and
they call it peace and you know in some
ways um you we're still making deserts
and calling them peace and he's
absolutely brilliant but as you say Rory
he was the world in real life he's Mr
collaborator he's in with the people
that he's criticizing he's taking their
Shilling and he's doing their jobs for
them yeah and I I think
um I mean for me as a as a working
politician I
felt such uh resonance because I felt
that British politics is deeply deeply
corrupting corrosive that you are worse
in mind body and soul that after a
decade as a politician you're not a
normal person anymore You' and that the
techniques for quiring power are like a
mask that you put on and The Mask turns
out to
be uh coated with some poison that
actually corrodes your
face um so yeah I I I I and I feel like
tacitus that we let ourselves down so
much we we are so much worse versions of
ourselves at the end of it do you think
it's worse now I mean it's it's very
easy to be nostalgic about the
politicians of the past partly because
we don't have their whatsapps or you
know whatever right um so we it's it's
easy to fall I think into a bit of a
trap of saying um you know once upon a
time you know we might not have agreed
with them but they were upstanding men
of principle who resigned with they did
something wrong um and now look at the
sesp of politics do we really think that
it was once a lot better I mean when
I've been listening to the co inquiry
which you know I felt a bit sort of
polluted listening to it but have also
been absolutely gripped you know um you
know and you see uh the Democratic heart
of British government being a very know
nasty
mess and just a little bit of me has
said maybe that's what British democracy
has always been like and people have
always been that corroded by it they've
always worn those masks we've just been
we've just not kind of known it quite so
close I don't know I think it's a very
it's a very important question I mean
clearly
for a lot of Romans they had an idea
that there was a period in the past
where Romans were better and it's
important for them at different periods
to look back to some sort of golden age
I don't know 150 BC or something where
Romans are behaving probably or 300 BC
or some moment where where uh Romans are
dignified and Grave and you know non-
luxurious and all this kind of stuff so
and and we don't and it's difficult
again this is where the cynicism of the
historian comes in I think the
Temptation for the historian to is to
say well this is all and
propaganda and those people in the past
were know better than they people later
um my suspicion is uh twofold firstly I
think it's even if it's not entirely
true it is absolutely essential that you
should have an idea of a better way of
doing things located in the past that
that is incredibly important to try to
maintain any former standard but I also
think that in the case of British
politics there were things that were
better I think our institutions are
genuinely collapsing not just political
institutions I think our universities
are in trouble I think our media is in
trouble I think our civil service is in
trouble I think institutions in general
are in trouble and one of the problems
is the replacement of a sense of
intrinsic value in work with a form of
careerism now you can simplify this and
think well there were always careerists
yes there were but the question is
what's the balance and my instinct is
that if you go
back and look at I don't know gladston
for
example yes of course he was a careerist
yes of course he cared about getting
promoted but my guess is for the sake of
argument 30% of his mind is caught up
with that and 70% of his mind is caught
up with trying to do his job but by the
time you get to Liz trust things are
very different right so in in just to
try to illustrate what it's like in in
when I become the environment Minister I
feel very very excited right here I am
I've suddenly become the environment
Minister I'm going to plant 100 million
trees I'm going to make the air quality
better in London I'm going to clean up
our beaches going to think about 25 year
environment plan I'm going to improve
the national parks and Liz truss who's
then the Secretary of State for
environment food and Rural Affairs to my
boss calls me in and she says Rory I
want you to write a 10-point plan for
the national parks so I say absolutely
brilliant I'll go off and do it I'll get
the chief executive national parks I
will do some consultation we'll come
back to you in a few weeks and she says
no I want it in two days time I want it
on Thursday night and I said was the sex
say it's impossible and she says a Rory
come on let me do it for you you know
number one let's get more young people
back into nature number two I don't know
clear up the rubbish national parks and
sure enough on Friday in the Daily
Telegraph Liz trusts his seven-point
plan for National Park thereafter she
never visits a national park as far as I
know she takes no interest in National
Parks the job is done at no point does
she think even for a moment that there
might be some fulfillment or
satisfaction in trying to take the fact
that she's responsible for National Park
seriously take an interest in what a
national park is and and that's where I
I I want to push back again the cynicism
of theori because I think there probably
were better Emperors and worse Emperors
and politicians and worst politicians
and that's partly about moral
standards